bonsoir
si vous le désirez nous allons voir ce
soir une comédie américaine réalisée par
melvil chat belson qui réunit cary grant
et sophia loren un cary grant lui
distingué que j'avais et une sophia
loren qui fait ses débuts dans la
comédie américaine auprès d'un
partenaire que lui envient
authentique star du pays parce que en
1951 donner la réplique à cary grant est
un honneur chèrement disputées
quand une belle dame italienne pleine de
charme vient tout exprès séduire un
monsieur américain type
eh bien ça donne une histoire d'amour
pleine de charme et de gaieté quand il y
a des sentiments il ya quelquefois des
larmes mais elle s'est vite parce que
cette péniche et la péniche du bonheur
le spectacle peut commencer
voyons la péniche nous l'avons même si
ce n'est pas exactement celle du film
elle est très belle tout de même le
bonheur ça pourrait être d'être ensemble
ce soir
quant à la comédie
elle arrive d'outre-atlantique dans un
instant je vous rappelle que le journal
de jean marie cavada terminera notre
soirée